still here honestly I talk on lambdas
last thing on a Friday you're hardcore
you have my respect you will have my
slides in a minute you have my respect
to begin with me okay so let's talk
about Landers um this is a phrase that's
been used a lot by programmers language
designers so I know I'm really what I
want to do is I want to get inside this
and say well okay so what is this thing
people keep talking about let's talk
white origin stories okay this is this
is basically the way that Hollywood
works you've had all the lambda features
released in your languages now it's the
origin story okay that we've released
that how do we monetize more lambdas
okay this is what we're going to talk
about and to understand a little bit
more about what's going on here it's a
nice letter it's it's one of the most
pleasing letters to write actually and
but there's this thing it has a number
of associations the Amazon completely
completely jumped on some crazy van
right so we're gonna call this thing
that's nothing to do or even remotely
like functions and lambdas we're going
to call it lambda that'll confuse
everybody because it's kind of like
function sort of yeah our PCs done
differently right
so yes nothing to do with that no it's
not to do with half-life which borrowed
it from the idea of the decay constant
in physics where it's also used as a
wavelength physicists like to recycle
their letters quite a lot
they don't use name spaces and then
there's calculus and that's the one that
we're kind of interested in now this all
came out of the work of Alonzo Church
and he published this paper in 1936 so
that's kind of the moment of Inception
except actually it isn't he published a
previous paper in 1932 which I have not
been able to get my hands on even via
the interwebs but this is the kind of
the basic reference point he did some
fixes in 1935 to some stuff and he
wasn't interested in what we are
interested in he was interested in
computability but in the same way that
cheering was is something computable as
opposed to how do I actually write a
program and he was exploring this an
unsolvable problem of element
number theory this was really just the
exploration of the insurance problem
which is related to the halting problem
and in the same year Turing came out
with similar proof that was shown to be
compatible but using Turing machines and
these was shown to be actually
equivalent and so there's so but as a
buyer by in this paper which I am not
trained as a mathematician so I kind of
I kind of reached a sort of a sort of
sheer g-force acceleration after a
couple of pages got really totally sure
I'm with you here on this one there's a
lot of assumed context but he just
tosses in learned calculus it's just a
very casual thing but it's also
interesting this is the 1930s and there
was this is a period at which it's worth
understanding where a number of
certainties about the future was
starting to be torn down and I'm not
making political references just yet but
I could easily do that it's there was
this idea at the end of the nineteenth
century that we had everything was
everything was knowable knowability
everything could be complete maths could
be consistent and complete and all of
this started tumbling down in the 1920s
the end of the 1920s thanks to Kirk
girdle and the incompleteness theorem we
discovered halting problem as a whole
series of things
by the way relativity came along to just
say oh yes black holes that was a nice
side effect of relativity which was 1915
when Einstein first presented it
properly published in 1916 and then
other people started working through the
know working through the equations going
wait a minute you know there's a really
weird thing here what we now call a
black hole a boundary of no ability and
it turns out that the 1920's 1930's came
along and tore down this edifice of like
everything is knowable oh by the way
quantum mechanics it's just like so that
was that that was that was the stage
which ultimately gives us this idea of
what we have is rigidly defined areas of
doubt and uncertainty that certain
things cannot be known and are no
but it turns out that lambdas are they
are knowable they were they were left as
a kind of theoretical thing something of
interest pretty much until the end of
the 1950s when McCarthy and others
started designing lists the first
implementation of the list was 1960 and
it was pretty much based on lambda
calculus and lambdas were a feature in
the language and this was kind of like
the first time this is just like right
made its way in to computing and these
days it's kind of like you know I just
did some googling around the other day
and there's this Ruby Ruby tutorial you
may have heard of Landers before perhaps
you've used them in other languages it's
just what it's now got to that point
where we kind of assume that people have
heard of them there's a strong
assumption
despite the fancy name I don't know
picking a letter is not particularly
fancy I mean you know dominant
programming languages through history
see what that's a fancy name no it's
just just because it chooses a letter
from a different alphabet it's like that
a lambda is just a function peculiarly
without a name and you know what this
actually means in terms of solving deep
significant problems it means that this
classic quote from Phil Carlton okay it
turns out too hard things and computer
science cache invalidation and naming
things we're done you know we've just
reduced it if land does mean you you
never have to worry about naming things
and cache of validation if you've doing
functional programming it turns out
there's no such thing as invalidation
because that's a process with a
side-effect nothing happens in
functional programming it's so purely
even if you unplug your computer your
functional programs will still run wait
a minute doesn't work yeah they're
riddled with side-effects that's all
that makes it all of this stuff is an
illusion okay functional programming is
an illusion every paradigm is an
illusion but yeah we can do that and
basically say right we've done if we can
go home you know there are no more
problems because it's also caching
validation is not relevant to this talk
either so what was Church
what's Church saying I said right okay
so we select a particular list of
symbols consisting of the symbols open
close curly open close parenthesis
lambda square brackets and an
innumerably infinite set of symbols ABC
etcetera to be called variables and we
define the wave formula to mean any
finite sequence of symbols out of this
list now this is a shift from the way
that people have and here within the
paper he also uses traditional function
notation from a mathematical perspective
and there's this very simple but subtle
idea that a function is a name and there
is a formula and the function begins
with a name and what we're doing is
we're basically saying you know what if
you do have a name it's just kind of
like on the side and that's an associate
that's a convenience but it's not a
fundamental idea and we're going to
shift this and we're going to treat
these things as first class that there
are only values and that's the thing in
lambda calculus there are only values
that are lambdas that will turn out to
be interesting a little bit later and so
here we have a very simple lambda
expression and I'm gonna use this to
demonstrate the basically the the three
rules of what makes a lambda a lambda
the first thing is variable that seems
trivial we we take these for granted but
this is the basic idea that you have
something that can hold a value that
value must be a lambda in pure lambda
calculus but you have a variable we'll
see in a moment has two kinds of
variables the next thing is you have
abstraction function abstraction where
what you're doing is saying that this
variable is bound within this context
over an expression Y of X and the y and
to be precise it's Y applied to x and y
is a lambda being applied to a value so
application so it turns out these are
the three things if you've got these
this is fundamental you have variables
you have function abstraction you have
application you've got that that's e it
now a couple of other things that thing
F that I had before that's an
abbreviation it's not formally par
of lambda calculus but it turns out it
gets quite boring when you have to write
everything out longhand yeah although he
wasn't saying don't repeat yourself
that's what he meant
these are convenience but this is really
important because it means just as an
aside I'm not a topic I'm going to cover
here it means that that is simply a
stand-in for that because it's not a
definition because it is an abbreviation
it basically means that you cannot refer
to F on the right-hand side which means
that lambda calculus does not support
recursion which is going to upset a lot
of people who've just thought whoa wait
a minute isn't that all the functional
programming there's this there's a whole
bunch of things called fixpoint
Combinator's that get kind of
interesting and maybe an extended
version of this talk I'll explore that
but these are just abbreviations they
turn out to be surprisingly convenient
the next thing is to look at the kinds
of variable we have bound variables that
comes in as a parameter that's your
classic parameter and free variables
that means that as defined somewhere
else and then that somewhere else is
kind of an interesting thing we'll come
to that in a moment so let's just look
at something fairly simple and what I'm
going to do is I'm going to introduce
something beyond lambda calculus that
little x symbols strictly speaking the
purest well the purest form of lambda
calculus has nothing else to it I just
showed you the whole thing and it got a
few reduction rules and that's it but
for convenience obviously we just like
yeah this is through some mathematical
stuff and let's make life a little bit
easier so we take our standard
definition of what is Square and we do
something like this so therefore this is
an abbreviation I apply that guess what
innumerably infinite symbols I'm not
saying Alonzo Church invented emoji but
he accommodated it he didn't say there's
a bound set he said no and that means
that that's a cross-product I know I
know that's terrible it does not get
better than that in fact we can do the
whole thing this is great so I can now
get square and he said he knew a
reemployment I'm gonna take him at his
word and so we comply that to seven or
we can do that or we can write the whole
format so there we see in its purest
form we've used simple types and we've
got a simple application we're very
strict about things like parentheses as
programmers about where they go that's
not the case of mathematicians it's just
like yeah feeling that he actually
switches through the page
how he does function application f
parens of X or f space X it says
parentheses are just there to make
things a little bit more visible I just
love to see I just love to see compilers
do that
it's just that yeah I think I understood
that you know I feel I understood that
I'm gonna go with this you know so
that's the kind of thing you can get
away with in a paper now let's make this
real javascript doesn't get more real
than that so traditional JavaScript we
we have we are we are brought up with
the idea of thinking we named functions
a function has a name that is your
starting point but actually we could do
it like this now there's an interesting
point about and one of the reasons I've
chosen JavaScript here it's not simply
that it is broad accessible but Brendan
Eich when he developed it in the mid-90s
we kind of the tale goes that it took
him two weeks to do a lot and then
there's half a dozen jokes that hinge
around the fact we're not quite sure
what he was doing in the second week but
actually what he wanted to do was
implemented version of scheme I will
come to scheme in a moment but people
said nobody's gonna buy that syntax
you've got to use familiar syntax so
basically it's it's kind of an
interesting mashup he said ok right I'm
gonna use C style syntax I'm going to
use I'm gonna use Landers I'm going to
use ideas from scheme so it's a list
based language I'm gonna use ideas from
there and I don't really want any of
that complex objects I'm gonna use a
really simple prototypical model of
objects and go with that but from the
very beginning it was always in there
now strictly speaking
some people would some people get very
fussy and say well I know that's not
really a lambda because it's just a
function without a name it turns out
that these are not necessarily
equivalent but some computer scientists
get get very upset about them being
regarded as equivalent so I'm gonna
treat them as equivalent so anyway what
we get is X script 6 comes along and
says you know we got this arrow form
we're gonna make life even easier and we
can they we've gotten more abbreviations
and actually if you've only got a single
expression then yeah black
very easy so this is all good this works
out really well let's go back to that
Ruby tutorial they're anonymous little
functional spires sneaking into the rest
of your code I don't like the sound of
that
I mean I've already got Facebook to
worry about and now you're telling me my
lambdas are gonna gang up on me but we
have a point here about the way that
people perceive them not the spy but the
functional bear people immediately
associate lambdas I say all right
lambdas that must be in function program
so 2014 Java gets lambdas lots of people
going like I am now functional
programming its Java mate you're not
functional programming
really yeah but I'm using Landers and
they're like totally functional it's
just like oh okay
let's let's take things down a bit let's
let's reduce our excitement here Excel
interesting enough which does not have
lambdas although it's been suggested I
don't know I think spreadsheets already
have enough bugs in them I'm not quite
sure that the public is ready for the
ladders but assignment page Jones mr.
Haskell basically med Association Excel
is the world's most popular function
language functional means a number of
different things to different people at
different times they start from
different positions some people say
write functional programming is rooted
in this for me it is lambda calculus for
other people on and I know it's to do
with hindley-milner type systems that is
functional programming to me it's kind
of like everybody has their own personal
version of this but I wanna go back to
list because this is the one that was
kind of interesting this just want to
trigger a number of ideas and there's a
certain beauty and elegance to the
original Lisp this is the manual for the
original Lisp as I have a copy of it at
home you can find a PDF online it's
quite it's quite brilliantly written as
she was written in the early 60s Lisp
1.5 there was supposed to be a list to
than ever was
the syntax they were going to tidy up
the syntax and make it less list
oriented but actually it turns out the
syntax they're merging between data and
code treating them as the same was not a
it was not a stepping stone idea it was
actually a really big idea and they were
kind of thought we're going to change
the sin
two accents just like now you know what
this is this something really good here
but we use Lisp generally to mean
anything that coming - looks like Lisp
there's a there's a monster called
Common Lisp which I've had to grapple
with in the past a couple of times
number of people are familiar with the
Emacs Lisp earless there's lots of
different flavors they're not all of
them were significantly larger than this
but this is sent elegance to it and I've
described to people you need to get
infatuated with this I don't think I've
ever been commit pay commercially to
write this code although I think I
managed to sneak some stuff that was
Lisp ish a couple of places but there is
an elegance to the thinking there's
something really clean and simple Alan
Kay of small talk Fame when he saw part
of some some of the ideas in this book
said basically that this page this is
the laws of physics or Maxwell's
equations to be precise for programming
of all languages in particular is really
aspired and that inspired a lot of small
talk come back to that a little bit
later and so we can always get carried
away with this and xkcd last night I
drifted off while reading a list book
suddenly I was baited as a fusion of
blue I noticed the coincidence that
actually I don't think Randall Munroe
intended it but that is the blue of the
original book and there it is nice
coincidence suddenly I was bathed in
this effusion blue once just like they
said I felt a great in light when I saw
naked structure of Lister code I'm fall
before me the patterns and meta patterns
dance syntax fade and I swam the purity
of quantified conception of ideas
manifest 2001 referenced there which if
you know Lisp is hilarious if you don't
don't worry about it truly this was the
language from which that gods wrote the
universe no it's not it's not I mean its
density yes honestly we hang most of it
together with Perl there is a certain
pragmatism to the way that things come
out and as for those red X's for quantum
mechanics you're on your own kid but
that does bring a rather interesting
point um lambdas really have got
everywhere to try and claim them for
your paradigm is it's not really gonna
work out I'm not no I'm not gonna do
anything with Perl I have a kind of a
there's a bit of me that won't let me do
Perl you know it's
it's kind of like Sethe speech I just
can't do it
it's not I'm not allowed to do it Perl
is executable line noise it's one of my
least favorite languages no like
languages but PowerShell let's use a
scripting language he's partial here's a
lambda that's the square it's quite nice
actually POW sure there's a surprisingly
good and well well for to our language
if I want to give it a name like oh yeah
I can just I can bind it to a name I can
apply up a really simple application
syntax there it is it's very direct and
that's it so I've got I've got these
options I can even do it this is prop
now you know it's a proper lamb because
you can just take that and you don't
need the name with which to execute it
that's that substitutability that
freedom the idea is that the name is
simply an abbreviation for something
else if you've got that this is a really
good thing then that's also while we
well you know let's go back to the 60s
again Algol 68 possibly the most
influential language you've never used
if you were all of those those are you
using languages where there's in a
keyword int yes that came from Al Gore
prior to that all language design
involved using the word integer int
character char that's where it all comes
void that came from Algol there's a load
of stuff it really is at the time it was
seen as this monstrously huge language
that would nobody would ever be able to
implement honestly the I've got a copy
of the language report it's it's kind of
really quite small compared to modern
languages this is not complex but you
know guess what one things I love about
Algol is it is unforgivingly procedural
it does the procedural paradigm properly
algorithmic language there it is it does
the procedural paradigm it's committed
to the procedural paradigm so committed
that you can have
unnamed procedures that's how committed
it is yeah they were a standard feature
it's a standard concept okay so I can go
ahead and I can you know bind this
simple anonymous procedure square so I
just want to remind you 1968 okay
Gouri because you all the other
languages going around is like yeah
Java's going like 2014 we got lambdas
and everybody else behind it's going
like hi c++ here that was 2011 for us
and c-sharp sitting going like come on
we're in the 2000s javascript in the
background going like yeah mid 90s Lisp
was going like yeah 1960 but somewhere
in there in the 1960s this was kind of a
normal feature of language design COBOL
did not have it but a lot of other
languages had this ability to have this
kind of procedural abstraction freely
available so I've got a declare it as I
you know it's it's a language that has a
concept of types doesn't do type
deduction so I do have to go ahead and
declare these things but you know I can
apply it I can also as we expect with an
application I can just apply it freely I
can just take that expression and apply
it to seven and it will give me the
square of that so it's a little bit much
to try and claim I am being pretty I've
just shown you scripting and procedural
I mean that's yeah it's not oh my
goodness lambdas and Ruby are also
objects just like everything else okay
we are not done with this paradigm
apparently so pick this one up from a
discussion group on which years ago
there was a discussion I dug out with
guy Steele and a number of other people
guy Steele was his kind of languages
expert had a hand in a number of
languages worthless son but prior to
that it's been involved in variety of
languages most notably scheme in the
1970s really nice bloke very very
knowledgeable but this was kind of a
response and somebody was kind of
describing it the pheromone Master croc
now I was walking with his student Anton
hoping to prompt the master into
discussion Anton said master I've heard
that objects are a very good thing is
this true
quick nah looks pityingly at his student
and replied foolish people objects am
merely a poor man's closures so closure
is a term that gets thrown around a bit
and actually wikipedia has one of the
best definitions oh god I dug around I
don't know you know I don't always like
to rely on Wikipedia except for the fact
that sometimes they absolutely Nayla and
it's a really good condensed tour of it
the concept of closures was developed in
the 1960s
that's a hell of a decade for the
mechanical evaluation expressions in the
lambda calculus they were invented to
solve this problem how do we take lift
this stuff off the page and use things
that we are familiar with now scope
binding variables things like that how
we do this piece of land in defines term
closure in 1964 is having an environment
part on a control part now what is
interesting is I encountered closures
there are things called closures in a
number of languages and I encountered
closures at one point in Borland's
Pascal had Delfy stuff and I thought
these are not closures they're just
bound methods you can't actually I can't
give you a chunk of code I can simply
say here's an object dot here's and
here's a method and that's I'm going to
pass you that bind that bound thing and
that's not really that's happen yeah
that's a that's re poor version of
closure but strictly speaking these kind
does kind of fit it's having an
environment partner control part it's
just that you can't do much about it
it's just that you have a very
restricted idea of what environment is
and what control is a a pointer to a
method but it must be a named method
that already exists so that's very
different to the lambda idea which is it
doesn't have to have a name in fact
we're not going to assume names the
environment parties the binding of the
names now importantly these ideas become
a little more popular for a number of
reasons John Moses creates landing with
introducing the term closure to refer to
a lambda expression whose open bindings
the free variables have been closed
while bound in the lexical environment
resulting in a closed expressional
closure in other words those free
variables we now have a regular concept
like that free-standing Y that refers to
this it's not totally free standing we
have an idea of scope if you like that
gets passed through this turns out to be
quite an important idea one that again
we take very much for granted but this
does also allow you to if you find
yourself one is absolutely fascinating
the pointless debates you know is a
lambda closure or a closure or lambda
there is now an answer a closure is a
lambda that had free variables if it has
no free variables in fact so Square for
example is not a closure because it is
fully self-contained all of its
variables are bound it takes X it only
uses X we're done
okay um now the bit of history that is
more important and interesting this
usage was subsequently adopted by Jared
Sussman and guy Steele when they defined
scheme in 1975 a lexical scope variant
of this variant of Lisp and from that
point on it became widespread that was
the kind of like the inception point for
the popularity of the term it started
taking it out to other people now that
becomes interesting let us go back to
Anton chastise Anton took his lead from
his master and returned to his cell
intent on studying closures he carefully
read the entire land of the ultimate
series this is a series of papers by guy
Steele and colleagues that kind of
showed how powerful lambdas were written
primarily in the 1970s but that name has
been taken and is used for a site that
dedicated function prone land to the
alternate ultimate series babe and it's
cousins and implemented a small scheme
interpreter with a closure based object
system now this book is sort of computer
science classic structure interpretation
in computer programs one of those books
that it's kind of everybody eventually
refers to few people have read has one
of the dullest titles but there's a lot
of really interesting stuff in there
that was by Gerald Sussman and partner
and Herald Abelson interesting thing in
here actually as an aside is the
Maxwell's equations as it were for
programming languages this is the scheme
interpreter written in scheme or the
heart of the scheme interpreter written
in scheme this is a that's demonstrating
a something we would sometimes refer to
as Homo iconicity the idea of a language
representing itself and this is part of
the same mind-bending stuff when you
first hear about cross compilers you
know I'm coming across that's like how
can you write a C compiler in C that
doesn't make sense yeah there's a couple
of extra tricks you have to get in there
but the idea is let us write this one
out and let us do this let us describe
the language in terms of itself and
translate that and then you've got the
kernel and you can kind of bootstrap
everything from there but it's a very
profound idea because it you can see
it's very simple it's a favorable font
it fits on once it fits on one slide and
that is kind of everything that you need
to make this stuff work
what is interesting is that Alan Kay did
the same for small talk
he wrote the basic idea of small talk in
small talk his he did this kind exact
Lisp ish type of thing and small talk is
all about closures and this idea however
whenever people sort of always talk
about purity I've just done it I just
did it with Excel and functional
programming it turns out this thing I
discovered a few years ago Dan Ingalls
was some of you work with Alan Kay at
Xerox PARC Dan Ingalls implemented the
first version of small talk 72 now small
talk is a language often touted as a
very pure object-oriented language for a
few people use it now very few people
have had hands-on with it
but its influence is is quite quite
marked in fact if you go and look at
Ruby a lot of that Matz was inspired
very heavily by ideas that he found in
small talk but what is interesting is
that Darin Ingalls took the small talk
version of this and implemented it at
home using basic it's kind of like it's
beautiful elegant object because it was
a time this is the 1970s time sharing
systems had just come in and what else
do you have available to you on a time
sharing system you didn't really have
high pact and pilots he was busy working
at home and it turns out that it basic
was the only language available so you
know you make do with what you've got
now this is kind of interesting because
you can actually see there's a little
bit here that says lambda and that's
kind of that's one of the more
interesting bits there we go lambda make
procedure bind the environment and do
all the rest of it that's all good that
turns out to be quite an important bit
in a paper published in the mid-70s
Sussman still point out they say well
here's why we did this we weren't just
inventing languages for kicks this
worked fell out of an initial attempt to
understand the activeness of actus Carl
Hewitt that come out in the early
seventies with this idea of computation
the actor model and Carl Hewitt has
written some crazy ideas I've read some
of the original papers I ended up doing
my master's degree thesis was on actors
and I have to admit the call here at
stuff was the least accessible and since
I understand the motivation what is what
is an actor is it is it an object is it
oh what actually is it so they they did
what a number of people did in academia
at that time is if you don't understand
something let's build a language to
understand it yeah and this was a part
of a series of languages there was a
kind of a culture in the AI community
back then of naming your Lisp variants
after something like well one of them is
called planner and other was called
mapper this was supposed to be called
schema you get the idea of what's going
on problem is there was a six six
character limit on file names so
schema-less one that trim down becomes
scheme hence the name scheme this
interpreter attempting to mix the use of
actors and list lambda expressions in a
clean manner now I saw a talk by guy
Steele 2005-2006 what was interesting is
he talked about this when it was
completed we discovered that actors and
the land of expressions were identical
and implementation in other words it
turns out that that bit there that says
lambda it turns out they had another bit
and they call them alpha expressions for
actor it turns out it was syntactically
identical this is the joy of having code
that fits on one page and they said wait
a minute it's exactly the same except
the names are different but other than
that it's structurally similar wait a
minute both mind-blown actors are Landis
Wow cool so that's where it all comes
from but that was the motivation so
we've now just unified another paradigm
with Landis at this point crook na has
another walk with Anton who tends to
impress his master by saying master I
had diligently studied the matter now
understand that objects are truly a poor
man's closures quick now I responded by
hitting Anton with his stick saying when
will you learn closures are a poor man's
object at that moment Anton became
enlightened this is kind of duality here
and it's one that we kind of pick up
it's a rather nice paper from 2009 will
you
cook it's based on revisiting a paper on
data abstraction and polymorphism that
was a very influential in the night in
1984 Lukic art daily peter Wagner
published it and William Kirk goes back
to it a number points he makes but one
of my favorite is lambda calculus was
the first object oriented language by
looking at a number of things related to
polymorphism and and and so on
and we can actually see this if we look
at so this is seven mountains just
outside Las Vegas as you can see the
data structure in use here is the stack
I'm going to be traditional with this so
you know here we have the quote this is
this is if you like this is a kind of a
functions as objects sometimes called
modules but and that's not that that
terminology is falling out of favor but
this is the purest object model that
lives inside of JavaScript there's quite
a few object models that live inside of
JavaScript and lots of different ways of
getting them but if you like this is the
one that most directly represents this
idea of closure and pure data
abstraction and so what we see here is
simply I've got the outer thing I'm
basically saying I've got a name that
I'm going to associate it's just the
abbreviation there's no cycles here
it's a lambda you call it and then you
will get a new thing a new record or a
new object that happens to have names
accessible depth top push and pop and
each one of these is bound to a lambda
each one of which is indeed a closure
because it's referring to a local
variable items that items list is about
as private as you can get it's an array
that is a local variable and it's it's
truly local that's bound in with the
scope so it's not it's not in the sense
it's not a there's not a keyword thing
going on here it's it's hidden because
it's hidden it's not hidden because it's
inaccessible that's a difference in
languages like C sharp and Java if you
say oh yes we've hidden this now you
haven't I can see right there on the
page I can do reflection and I can see
it right there that field it's there you
just said you can't access it I can
perfectly well see it but you just can't
access it whereas here it's just like no
there is nothing this is the bottom of
the iceberg so this takes us to to
another paradigm and a lot of people
associate structured programming with
the idea of go to free programming so
this book was published in 72 based on
work in the late 60s and early 70s and
in it they make a really important point
well the most powerful mechanisms of
program structuring is the block and
procedure concept so I'm gonna give you
some code here that is based on a
language based on Algol 60 predecessor
of Algol 68 and what we're going to do
is going to have an array of items one
to capacity you couldn't have
dynamically sized arrays so one to
capacity or other you could not have
dynamically allocated is it you can
capacity as long as that's in an outer
scope we can allocate that on the stack
and it's got a reference to Rox
and we're going to keep a count of how
much of that capacity we've used just as
a general point you have a nil there
isn't there is then there is a null
reference here this is the null
reference that was borrowed from another
language in the algal family algal W and
Tony Hoare kind of feels he is
responsible for inventing null which he
calls a billion dollar mistake but this
is where it comes from and then we can
actually be we can we can go ahead and
initialize that and because it's a
proper block structured language and
this is the thing I think we've also
forgotten what block structured
originally meant it meant that you could
put anything in a block that means if
you want to put a procedure in a block
you can put a procedure in a block it's
as simple as that
there's no idea of there's a top level
and you can't define nested things it
turns out curiously that a number of
languages are kind of caught up with
this one a little bit late so c-sharp
said you know what we're gonna have
these kind of like you know you can have
these kind of methods nested inside your
methods this idea is a very very old one
but that idea being able to offer
operations desktop push and pop on that
is interesting so that's a block of code
that's your begin and end that's your
open and closing curly
a procedure which is capable of giving
rise to block instances now that's kind
of interesting because given the
specialist we're talking about stacks
the whole point here is that normally
when you think about blocks its stack
discipline you enter a block you get
your variables you do you work you leave
the block and that's all gone okay it's
gone there are no more variables that's
it that some of those objects may live
on thanks to the garbage collector but
they're on there that's done there is a
very simple idea here what if it doesn't
go away what if the block is itself a
thing huh what if what have you returned
the block and say look I've got a block
and it's got procedures in it and it's
got variables it's got state here have
this you can use it and that was the
beginning of object orientation the
language in question so here we go which
survive it's called be known as claw
clasp and the instances will be known as
objects of that class and classes did
not have to be named they could be
anonymous just like lambdas you could
have unnamed classes but I'll show you
the named version what I do is we take
that and then we just simply add that at
the top and we're done and that's where
so this is this is similar 67 the first
object-oriented language it's based on
Algol 60 and it follows exactly that
idea of why don't we take a block and
then add the idea that the block doesn't
go away when you've left it it can
become a thing that you can refer to wow
you can create a whole paradigm out of
that and again the land earnest of that
is it's pretty cool we could of course
use any notation we want to not laugh at
notations invent them they are powerful
so Nobel laureate Richard Feynman made
this observation in fact mathematics is
to a large extent invention of better
notations so let's talk about that
Alonzo Church was asked why do you why
did you choose lambda and there are a
number of different origin stories the
one that is the most rational it goes
like this you've got an abstraction you
basically want to say I've got a a is a
bound variable I want to show I want to
show an abstraction with respect to that
and his original form was this it was a
carat okay it's good put it don't by the
way this also means something I haven't
said so far and I'll state it lambdas
can only take one parameter because if
you forgot that notation
does make sense to have two parameters
you can't do lands can only take one
thing and return another and that was
that problem is and trust me you get a
lot of trouble trying to find an a
circumflex don't worry about your
infinitely innumerable symbols it's
quite tough if you're a typesetter in
the 1930s you go like come on mate
really give us a break what about that
there we go that's the story that makes
the most sense later in his life Church
gave other stories which is I liked it
yeah whim that was it you know why not
yeah but I like that story because it
also helps demonstrate some of the
aspects of what lambda is so what are
the other languages do well they took
lambda and you know some of them
imaginative Lee called their lambda
abstraction lambda okay so this is what
Lisp did this is what scheme did if you
work in Python this is what Python does
Haskell kind of said dude that's so
verbose there we go
everything you need to know that is one
of the most minimal notations out there
clearly you've got stuff like JavaScript
came along and said we have to call it
function and then you get blank just
like closure so a kind of a lisp variant
running on the JVM it decided to call it
FN because clearly you know vowels
they're bad so in some languages you get
func in other language you get fun here
hmm
now what I consider this to be
profoundly ironic it basically means
that closure has anonymous functions but
it has there is nothing in the language
that is called a lambda what is the logo
for the language a language that does
not have anything called lambda there
you go it's either ironic or deep or
quite possibly both we get C++ is a
great one this is actually you get
choice of whether you want to catch a
closure or not so we get square brackets
now this get some great syntax this is a
valid token sequence in C++ okay what it
is is this is a lambda that captures
nothing takes no arguments and does
nothing and here's how you execute it so
this is kind of so this doesn't this is
silence of the Landers if you like I
told you they weren't going to get any
better so then we get all the language
we've got JavaScript we've got c-sharp
we say you know we're gonna go for this
arrow notation and then you've got some
other folks you know groovy and Javas
like now we're gonna be more we're gonna
be much more lightweight
see that's much more lightweight it's
just like yeah but it's kind of
interesting because here it isn't Java
here's the thing that does nothing well
I have an interesting question how do i
execute that that's a language brush in
java well how do i excuse me thing but
how do i execute it and we have exact
the same problem in c-sharp how do i
execute that it here's the thing that
does nothing how do i execute that now
it's kind of an interesting one cuz it
actually opens up a number of issues
because what is the type of the return
well in the original and calculus there
was only one type there are only lambdas
that's it but we have grown used to
languages that have a very particular
vocabulary and set of concepts the
languages most names that I've described
so far are C based languages which have
their origins in Algol you know the
syntax has shifted but all of the ideas
are there and there's a fundamental idea
in all of these languages you have
expressions and all expressions have a
type clearly that's we can kind of say
well you know the original lambda can't
care but what is the type of that
expression in c-sharp what is the type
of that expression in Java these are C
related languages in terms of their
concepts of a category but it turns out
that we cannot name weak well I just
don't even case we can't name it it
turns out that they don't actually have
a type they're not expressions in the
conventional sense
the original lambda calculus is often
referred to as untyped there's been a
move recently people have described unit
types which is kind of cool if you want
to you know confuse your colleagues if
you're having one of those dynamic
versus static
like debates and you think it's getting
away from you just throwing new
terminology you know this is on type oh
I think you'll find it's you know typed
you know it's like the type of the web
is in the string
yeah the type of the enterprise is the
core dump you know this is there's lots
of different ideas of what there is one
true type but yeah shell scripts are
historically you know typed around
string they are streaming typed but
there is only lambdas so this is kind of
interesting what do we do now clearly
having just untyped lambda calculus is
annoying and in fact Church later
developed a simple typed calculus and a
number of other people kind of assume
that it's just like yeah I want my
convenience I want to use lambdas as a
vehicle in the context of other things I
don't want to have to build everything
up from scratch that's a little bit yeah
Baima ones and zeros together I haven't
really moved to a very high level so we
normally assume that there is a type
system but we let's go have a look at
what languages do if we go to Haskell
that is our square in the shell I can go
ahead and ask what's your type I don't
tell me and it has a well-defined type
this works with classes of numbers and
gives you a result that is of the same
type there you go
it has a type the type is determined in
c-sharp oh nope so it's C++
it has a type you cannot name the type
the type is anonymous but it has a type
that can be deduced and you can use it
it has a type that has certain syntax
associated with it if I go to python i
can sit there and wrap that expression
in type and i will get an answer
yeah it'll tell me hey this is a
function this is an object of class
function but if I go to c-sharp and try
and get type this does not work out
quite so well for me
operator dot cannot be applied to
operator type language question that's
it no explanation I'm sorry do not pass
go but why you just can't do that's been
frustrating well tell you what maybe
I'll just put it into a variable
yeah same dealer again no explanation
you just can't do it
yeah but why no I'm telling you why it
turns out that you can that's one of the
kind of the key distinction so this is
the interesting thing it turns out
that's not a lambda I mean it's called
the lambda but it's not a lambda you
know you can call it with what you call
it fret you know I'm not going to argue
is your choice of names there but that
is not a language question because I
cannot it doesn't support application to
get it to do anything I have to do that
now technically speaking based on
everything I've just said this is a
lambda expression that bit away from the
type is not a lambda expression
so there are lambdas the dart lambdas
and there are other things that we don't
call the Landers that our lambdas and
you know what about Java
yeah what about Java it's slightly well
at least we got to use normal function
call or method call syntax here you only
hit Java it gets a bit Messier because
Java doesn't have this idea it basically
says you can't do any kind of there's no
abstractions for operator overloading or
being able to hook into that in the
language that simply doesn't exist and
so for yeah there's a bit of a
compatibility issue here in fact there's
a bit of a consistency issue that is not
a lambda but if I execute it I can't
just put her ends around it like a
method so it doesn't behave like a
functional abstraction the other
function abstractions in the language it
turns out there's a whole library of
interfaces that I can use to wrap
lambdas and I can also apply my own but
those are not the type of the thing they
are things you know there was the JIT
LAN just used to generate something but
I can then give it a type and it's a big
it's a big old mess it's a big old mess
and that's just the basic variants
that's one and two parameters and deals
with the fact that generics aren't
rarified in the language there's a lot
of duplication here so did they choose a
consistent name given I'm not you given
that we understand that normally how you
call a functional abstraction is to use
open parens closed parens that's one
that is the one syntax to rule them all
so surely they must have chosen one name
one consistent name and now they didn't
some of them are called apply some of
them are called test
some call the sect and someone will get
so there are four different names
actually turns out this five because if
we want to do this one there's run now
sometimes people said well yeah we don't
we don't have enough information to
deduce the types and that's quite
reasonable because these expressions
tend to be very light a lot of deduction
needs to go on what's the return type
well that's how we have to have a look
what's the you know what what are the
parameter types well we're going to have
to look at context but I've just given
you an expression that has no context
it's bound to nothing it takes no
arguments returns nothing it really is
if you're looking for the type it's void
void so there's no deduction to be done
here but we have to jump through the
hoops here so yeah it turns out the
c-sharp and java do not support the
third of the three things so they are
very useful but they are not really
strictly lambdas now it may come as no
surprise that Alonzo Church doesn't care
about any of this not simply because he
is yea long since deceased but this was
not the problem he was trying to solve
it turns out the lambdas came out to be
useful for other reasons but his
original motivation was something well
it was to do with numbers countable
numbers innumerably infinite sequences
of numbers and do they have well can we
find an end to things yeah is there a
finiteness to certain sequences of
execution or not this is a very simple
question turns out has ridiculously hard
answers so this observation I've got
must have forward slumped against the
bulkhead and started to count to 10 he
was desperately worried one day sentient
life-forms would forget how to do this
only by counting could humans
demonstrate their independence of
computers so of course remember I just
said right back at the beginning and
I've kind of none cheated it every now
and then if you do pure lambdas there's
no numbers because there are only
lambdas can you go do arithmetic when
you've got no numbers well the answer is
obvious you invent them you know you
create your own numbers so we're gonna
start with nothing
and this is in fact the curiously enough
Church did not you need a zero in his
original paper but here's a zero and I
here is a lambda that takes two
parameters effort an X X is itself
actually a function but I'm just
choosing names that look a little more
obvious and here we're not going to
apply F to X we're just going to return
X with one we're going to apply it once
to X with two we're going to apply F to
the result of F to the result of X with
three we're going to so you see what's
going on here is what we've done is we
defined our numbers as the application
of a functional thing an application of
a lambda to something else and the
number of times we apply it repeatedly
is the number that is the thing that is
how we distinguish it so four is
equivalent to that five and so on I
won't go in numeral infinite on you
there are a couple of observations we
could write it like that there are some
shorthands in fact to be consistent we
could write it like that I'm not going
to do that here I want the full form
also I told you that lambda is strictly
speaking only take one parameter but
it's a shorthand and it's in the
original paper that you can basically go
oh lambda FX that's understood as being
lambda F got lambda X and notationally
that's convenient it just means that
everything is curried if you've done
highschool or looked at all this kind of
stuff all that's for free that was built
in but I can use this long form cuz it
makes it a lot easier to turn this into
JavaScript now I know if those of you
who work JavaScript already know that
JavaScript has a really weird idea of
numbers so we're not missing anything by
skipping it so here we go
I'm going to have underscore 0 a so the
thing things nice about JavaScript
choice of notation is this is actually
one of the lightest I've done this in a
number of languages because I have a
certain masochistic streak and honestly
JavaScript is one of the easiest to do
this it's syntactically light and you
can really see when you've gone wrong
but yeah so basically we've now
recreated the number system awesome but
how do we know that it works well
what is that this is a thing that does
stuff we aren't actually defining or we
are defining numbers by and/or as it
were application this is the thing that
doesn't apply a thing
what's it not going to apply well I'm
gonna plug in some good old-fashioned
JavaScript I'm gonna take an increment
you receive an argument and you add one
to it and that's your result
so we're not going to apply that because
it's 0 and what is it that we're not
going to apply it to well I'm going to
use the original 0 in the language so
we're not going to do that and what's
the result of doing this 0 it's a
JavaScript 0 what happens when we do it
once one applies F n becomes n plus 1
once which gives us that and then we see
so in other words the numbers these are
this is called the church encoding these
are church numerals which of you here if
you read that out of context it makes
you think since I talking Roman
Catholics here what are we worried over
here Church numerals so these are church
numerals this is a really cool idea it's
moderately insane why don't have curacy
enough one of the best best explanations
of it i came across was in shadows of
the mind
no no emperor's new mind by roger
penrose which is a book about why it is
that we will have create consciousness
and a bunch of quantum mechanics and
stuff but and ultimately you tend to
think he's got a very he has a great
mind but he's gone wrong but it has one
of the best explanations of this and i
think this is one of the first places i
encountered it's just ok so numbers can
be considered to be the act of applying
something to repeat a number of times
that's really cool
ok um let's go back to our friend square
so here's a really simple way of
implementing it we take a thing if 2 2
is is the tunis of something i'm going
to take em and I'm gonna apply it to em
huh
so that's squared I'm gonna apply em to
em how many times well that's twice it's
no I'm gonna do that
what happens if I put seven in well
seven is a thing that's a counting thing
so I'm gonna apply seven seven times and
seven does seven things so huh this is
really cool because we can now apply
this straight to start with zero and the
answer you've been waiting for since the
opening minutes of this talk yes it is
49 okay but we've just recreated numbers
now why stop there why stop there
19th century let's go back to the 19th
century when we thought we could solve
and know everything was knowable
everything was logical Victorian
engineering it reaches Peaks like yes
the world can be understood through
engineering through mass we will you
know everything will be understood and
the optimism is apparent in this
gentleman's book title very very these
days people just refer to it as the laws
of thought but clearly this is Victorian
era people still in too long book titles
and investigation of the laws of thought
which are on which I found the
mathematical c et cetera so there's
beautiful optimism that actually we
think logically come the late 20th
century that that edifice was torn down
hugely it turns out that logic is the
thing that you learn we are a mess logic
is a tidiness that can only be acquired
through education by our default state
is to be messy and irrational I refer
you to the activities outside was
evening so what did he do for us well he
basically formalized propositional
calculus and you know we live in a post
truth era so I thought I'd just show you
this just so yeah before you lose sight
of what it is and false you know what
you can church and code this I can apply
it so lambda a B truth is a falsehood is
B so I'm now got shrim Fosters pretty
cool if you look carefully although I've
used different names you may recognize
this if I did this as f and X you may
recognize this as zero so for all those
of you wondered is false zero is that is
that just a programmer thing no it's
actually built into the foundations of
lambda calculus that zero is false so
next time you have one of those debates
depending on where you stand on it but
if you ever need to justify your
gratuitous abuse of a language feature
and this happens to have been what
you've done you have a justification for
it just refer them to the paper they'll
never get through it it's our friend
small talk and what it's small talk well
this is the whole thing small talks idea
of what is truth and falsehood is not
there is a symbol called true and there
is a symbol called false truth and
falsehood do different things so truth
does one thing this is polymorphic if I
give a and B to a thing that is true I
will get a back I'll get the a part so
I'm basically created the basically
if-else here which is kind of neat so we
can take this a bit further it turns out
you can get really carried away with
this pair was originally introduced so
pair is you take an ax and a Y and then
you bind them together with an F and you
kind of glue that together you can pass
it around you can pass it around to an
operation first which will return you
the X well I'll pressure second which
will return you the Y if you look very
closely at those you realize that first
is basically pair true second is pair of
false this is quite nice all you need to
do now is add nil and you just
reinvented Lisp
so it's ridiculously powerful for words
I'm not suggesting that you got to go
out and just like just say look don't
worry about the optimize will take care
of it I'm go I am NOT going to use these
mere mortal numbers and integers that
you you've been talking about using you
that domain-driven design thing of yours
we are going to build things from the
purest of the pure you know oh you mean
you're gonna use zeros and ones serious
once do we're gonna use landis we're
gonna make our own zeros and once this
is the craftsmanship movement we make
our own zeros and ones finely-crafted so
I'm going to end with a exploration of
one of the most teasing challenges
fizzbuzz what was interesting as a
number of years ago I guess it was about
ten years ago I was reading a piece by
Tom Stewart and it's called programming
with nothing and I suddenly realized I
know what you're doing it was a ruby
piece and Tom solved it like this now
this is not a language you're familiar
with and I just said Ruby
well what did he do well what he did is
he basically programmed with nothing he
had those three properties I can have a
name of a thing a variable I can have
lambdas and I can apply a lambda that is
it and he built up and these are all the
abbreviations so he built up all of
these concepts he built the numbers 3 5
50 100 he built logic he built iteration
he did the whole thing and you can find
that on blog programming with nothing
but he also included it in his book
understanding computation he also
included the full form if you expand it
from the abbreviations that's what it
looks like you know it is one of the
crazier versions of fizzbuzz I have ever
encountered yeah yeah this is it yeah
this is the kind of stuff you give to
somebody could you just work this one
out for me you know I I need some more
detail here yeah good luck debugging
that by the way so we found is this idea
of lambda it was in one sense of
mathematical curiosity it helped solve a
problem it was shown and it was to do it
the fact it was such a simple formalism
that even numbers could be encoded in it
and it had rules of reduction and
therefore you had very simple operations
it turns out integers on their own are
surprisingly hard we tend to think it
was quite easy there's a whole load of
stuff it's the idea of what I want to
understand certain sequences if I can
encode everything in the simplest form
then I can provide proofs about it and
this turned out to be incredibly
convenient but this idea of an
abstraction that was not about things
but about doing if you like it's about
functions that's not the usual candidate
for this stuff we normally mass was
always phrased in terms of of objects or
things not objects in the arrow sense
but of things of entities here we are
talking about something that is much
more intangible a much more first class
idea a function rather than function
being a convenience it was actually a
thing
and we can reduce everything down to
that so there is nothing else and this
proved to be surprisingly powerful so
powerful in fact that when people
started thinking about well what how do
you build up simple languages how do we
do this this idea freestanding functions
whether we take it at its rawest level
or start saying you know if I know how
to just pass a piece of doing stuff to
us around rather than having to name
everything you only I could just create
everything and just pass it around and
we discover that that's actually been
infused in a number of different
paradigms obviously there is a natural
home in functional programming for this
but what we first see is that that is
not restricted to that that every
paradigm has ultimately ended up
claiming it as its own because of that
convenience so I hope that has been
thought-provoking and that you managed
to stay awake and that is provoked some
thoughts in you maybe you can just gonna
go home and drink that away or maybe
you're gonna go home and say alright ok
let's just try this I can do this let's
try a little bit church encoding COBOL
yeah yeah
but yeah good good luck with that thank
you very much
[Applause]